welcome back to Las Vegas now did you
gain the quarantine 15 if you did you're
not alone our friends at image Med Spa
want to make you make you feel good on
the outside and on the inside as we
emerge from our homes to poolside also
keep in mind this segment was done prior
to cope at nineteen and new safety
measures are now in place take a look
yeah
definitely getting tighter your debt
you're definitely tightening up for sure
and you're definitely losing fat I've
softened up a lot last week back that's
what you call it results after saying no
to CoolSculpting and yes to cryo tea
shop with Skyler over at image med spa
and it's actually going to do a full
customized treatment that's what I like
about the coyote shark CoolSculpting are
set applicators that are set for thirty
five minutes so they only treat what's
set into that hole smoking applicator
where this is actually doing the full
entire abdomen so we're clicking Mel
we're clicking abdomen the cryo tea
shock or cryo thermogenic machine can
actually do fat removal and skin
tightening the reason why I can do those
is because after you lose the fat you
actually want to tighten and tone up
that skin I'm going to hit the start
button and it's automatically gonna go
to read it first keeps up the fat cells
raises them to the surface and then we
are gonna go ahead and freeze those
suckers away so what does it feel like
so it feels like a massage kind of like
a set of hot stone maybe it's like a
cold stone massage so image client Chris
that he works out but because of
genetics he just can't seem to get rid
of that stubborn fat in his stomach and
his love handles he is getting the
treatment to get summer ready as you can
see we just went from red to blue which
now is starting the cold after about one
to two minutes he's actually gonna be
numb he's not even gonna feel the
pinching are you feeling the pinching as
it is and overall this is actually
freezing and crystallizing the fat this
is the second step to t shock so we are
pinching and then we're holding the cold
air and it's doing like what a suction
applicator of cool sculpting does
although it's getting more of an even
texture on average a client needs three
to six sessions a tea shock for the best
results that kills about 38 to 40
percent of fat cells in the treated area
once they're gone they're gone for good
a lot of people don't realize that
you're set with a certain amount of fat
cells and you stop producing it
adolescent
so when you gain weight they're just
expanding and when you lose weight
they're just shrinking so this is a true
non-invasive alternative to liposuction
and there's no downtime most people can
just casually come in on a lunch break
or right after work image med spas hours
cater to everyone you can come in as
early as 8:30 a.m. in the morning and we
find ourself freezing fat until like 12
sometimes 1:00 or 2:00 in the morning
it's also totally safe and only targets
your fat cells we're not touching any
other organs or anything it's actually
going after the fat and fat only so it's
selectively killing the vessel image med
spies all about boosting that double
image the one on the outside and on the
inside they offer a variety of services
to help image mitzva is actually a
one-stop shop we offer everything that
treats from head to toe from starting
out at teeth whitening to Botox and
fillers fat reductions cellulite
reduction skin tightening treatments
hair removal and then as far as like
thinner we're talking about like medical
weight loss testosterone therapy we've
got a solution for almost everything all
right Thank You Skylar for more
information call 702 nine seven two nine
four six six or just head to image
Medspa comm we'll be right back